[Música]
Estas son las noticias de Franz 24
confirmada la segunda vuelta
presidencial en Brasil con más del 99%
de El escrutinio completado se
enfrentará el presidente Jair bolsonaro
que logró el
43.26% de los apoyos y el ex mandatario
Luis Ignacio Luna da Silva que recibió
48,35%. Tenemos reporte desde la ciudad
de Río de Janeiro con nuestra
corresponsal
y ya son al menos 85 los fallecidos por
cuenta del huracán Ian desde que tocó
tierra en el estado de Florida el pasado
miércoles antes de degradarse siguen en
marcha las tareas de rescate y se espera
que los decesos aumenten a medida que se
logra acceso a zonas que están inundadas
y en Ucrania el presidente de ese país
bolodímir excelencia aseguró que la
liberación de los territorios de manos
rusas no se limita solamente a la Ciudad
de Lima donde ya finalizaron los
combates el mandatario dijo que también
se recuperaron poblaciones en la región
de gerson hoy además conversó con el
presidente francés Emmanuel macco sobre
el estado de la planta nuclear de
saporiya
muy buenas noches Bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González Gracias por estar con nosotros
hasta ahora
las elecciones presidenciales de Brasil
se decidirán en una segunda vuelta
electoral el 30 de octubre entre el
presidente de la derecha Jair bolsonaro
Y el dos veces ex mandatario
representante de la izquierda Luis
Ignacio Luna da Silva con más del 99% de
la escrutinio de las máquinas de
votación Lula sumó el
48.35% de los votos y bolsonaro el
43.26% de los apoyos lo que deja ver un
balotaje apretado para este mes el
resumen de la jornada lo tiene nuestra
corresponsal en la ciudad de Río de
Janeiro Valeria saccone
al final Habrá segunda vuelta será el 30
de octubre entre el presidente Jair
bolsonaro y su opositor Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva que tiene 5 puntos de
ventaja según los resultados de la
primera vuelta sin embargo bolsonaro ha
salido bastante reforzado de esta
primera vuelta por varias razones los
sondeos le daban un 36% de intención de
Voto y él ha conseguido el 43%, además
ha conseguido que se eligiesen varios
aliados tanto en el senado ex ministros
de peso de su gabinete como también en
los estados federados que tenían que
elegir a sus gobernadores concretamente
el Río de Janeiro tlayo Castro ha salido
elegido en la primera vuelta así como
sema en el estado populoso de minas
gerais y en San Pablo el colegio con más
electores 34 millones tarcisio
exministro de infraestructuras ha salido
muy bien parado llegar a la segunda
vuelta contra hadad que es representante
del partido de los trabajadores y tiene
todas las pintas de poder ganar nos
esperan cuatro semanas de campaña muy
intensa y lo que esperan los electores y
el país es que sean pacíficas Ya que en
la primera vuelta ha habido muchos casos
de agresiones e incluso tres
izquierdistas muertos a manos de
personalistas después de que se
pronunciara la autoridad electoral de
Brasil el ex presidente Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva recordó que nunca ha
ganado una elección en una primera
vuelta y dijo que muy a pesar de sus
oponentes aún tiene 30 días para ganar
la presidencia también aseguró que
conversará con otras fuerzas opositoras
para la contienda tenemos que
convencerlos de lo que estamos
proponiendo
Tenemos que hablar con las otras fuerzas
políticas que nos disputan en las
elecciones y lo siguiente la lucha
continúa hasta la victoria final
nosotros
Esperamos contar con el apoyo
de cada uno de ustedes
es incansable lo que ustedes hacen con
los candidatos
voy a intentar arreglar el Brasil
Asimismo se pronunció desde la capital
Brasilia el presidente candidato y
aspirante a la reelección Yair bolsonaro
quien además celebró las ganancias en
las elecciones legislativas para su
partido el partido liberal dijo además
que como advirtió en campaña las
encuestas se equivocaron en esta ronda y
que confía en su Victoria para la
segunda vuelta
confianza total
porque porque
yo creo que
según las encuestas
dio el del 51 el 30 y poco a mí
eso ayuda
a aumentar las fuerzas del otro lado
A que no exista
yo creo que ahora ya no van a confiar en
esas encuestas claro como se equivocaron
bueno sin duda Brasil cap atención
internacional en este momento pero hay
otros hechos destacados de la jornada
cientos de personas marcharon en las
calles de Ciudad de México para
conmemorar el aniversario número 54 de
la masacre de estudiantes que
protestaban En
1968 a finales de los años 60 las
fuerzas de seguridad irrumpieron en una
manifestación de estudiantes ligados a
la izquierda política de ese país en el
distrito de Tlatelolco en la capital
mexicana y mataron a entre 30 y 40
personas según funcionarios o hasta 300
personas según los activistas de los
derechos humanos y testigos de los
hechos los asesinatos ocurrieron pocos
días antes de los Juegos Olímpicos en la
urbe cuando el gobierno trató de sofocar
semanas de lo que consideró vergonzosas
manifestaciones de estudiantes que
exigían reformas democráticas en el
México autoritario de esa época
y el número de muertos por cuenta del
huracán Ian subió ya a 85 esos son
cifras para el cierre de este domingo
cuando los son residentes de Florida y
de los estados de las carolinas
enfrentaron las perspectivas de una
recuperación que se espera cuesta
decenas de miles de millones de dólares
se espera que el número de Muertos siga
aumentando a medida que las aguas de las
diferentes inundaciones retrocedan y los
equipos de búsqueda hacia adentren aún
más en áreas que están aisladas por
cuenta de las inundaciones cientos de
personas han sido ya rescatadas mientras
los trabajadores de emergencia revisaban
también algunas casas y edificaciones
que han sido inundadas por el agua o
completamente arrasadas por las aguas
que ha dejado el huracán
y en otros temas el presidente ucraniano
Bolivia mercelenski dijo este domingo
que el éxito de los soldados de su país
no se limita solamente a la reconquista
de Lima que fue anunciada el día de ayer
ya que también han sido liberadas
algunas ciudades de la región de gerson
se lensky también dijo que el jefe de su
oficina se reunió con el asesor de
seguridad Nacional de Estados Unidos
Jake Sullivan y con el asesor principal
del presidente Turco rechef adoan se
pronunció además sobre esa discusión que
tuvo con el presidente de Francia Manuel
majó en torno al Estado de la planta
nuclear de saporilla nosotros también
hemos discutido la situación en la
planta de energía nuclear de saborilla y
el secuestro del director general
igormudashop por parte de los ocupantes
rusos es otra manifestación más de Rusia
completamente Clara terror por el cual
el estado terrorista debe recibir un
castigo cada vez mayor y Finalizó el
festival biarritz América la en esa
ciudad costera del suroeste de Francia
que da nombre a ese encuentro la cinta
colombiana Los reyes del mundo de Laura
Mora fue premiada como la mejor película
el informe es de María Carolina piña
desde biarritx en el Mundo perfecto mío
el que no quiera
no existe Colombia se llevó el premio el
abrazo al mejor largometraje por la
cinta Los reyes del mundo de Laura Mora
la película relata la historia de rap un
muchacho de la calle que emprende con
sus amigos un viaje de Medellín al bajo
cauca para recuperar las tierras que le
fueron robadas a su abuela una
desplazada del conflicto armado
para mí definitivamente el arte en
general El buen arte Debería ser
político y con eso no quiero decir
militante y a mí me atraviesa mucho la
obsesión sobre la justicia esos premios
son una posibilidad de que se vea la
película de que la película pueda viajar
más y pueda tener un diálogo más amplio
con el público en el mundo
estamos muy emocionados pero yo todavía
no me lo creo mucho extorsión secuestro
robo de material clasificado viendo
laburones
el premio del Jurado fue para una
comedia negra Argentina punto rojo de
nicanor loretti quien hizo reír al
público con esta cinta que mezcla
Thriller mucha creatividad visual y
Pasión por el fútbol
la verdad que Fue increíble verla con el
público de biarritz porque es un gran
público y mucha gente va a ver todas las
películas una sala enorme siendo una
película subtitulada de humor donde hay
humor negro y la reacción las risas del
público con el humor fue muy
gratificante la verdad el Jurado
percibido por el director francés
Enrique plástico se felicitó por la
fuerza del cine latinoamericano
lo que más nos emocionó a todos en el
Jurado es ese espíritu desesperado al
mismo tiempo libre del cine en
latinoamericano Vimos a una América
Latina que sigue estando conmocionada y
al mismo tiempo que es súper potente
[Música]
esto en las noticias buenas noches